superlatives time coming out of week
four the spot where we come up with uh
funny and not so funny names of awards
for various players to give folks a
broader swath of recognition for what
they did on sunday instead of getting
caught up in the obvious storyline so
with that chris what do you got for me
first award of the week in the week four
superb well i'll i'll go i'll give it to
uh the bombs away award to drew brees
yep that's right even though he didn't
throw any bombs yesterday we don't need
to it was bombs for that offense and
when i say that i mean 15 20 25 yard
completions we saw that back in the
saints offense yesterday and with that
we saw more more explosive plays
and really after kind of getting down
early
i mean they went on a run there you know
tipped interception early
lions made a good drive it's 14 nothing
breeze and company went right down the
field and really controlled the game and
just you look at this graphic here i
mean you could see
you know 30 36 as compared to 20 percent
throwing the ball downfield from 10 to
19 yards 20 plus yards downfield yeah he
threw a few yesterday and i think that's
going to go a long long way to them
you know not being like overly
aggressive or crazy aggressive they
don't need to do that they just have to
have enough of it to scare you every
week for you just oh man we gotta defend
this part of the field it can't just be
10 yards all crushed in the middle if
they can just get a little of emanuel
sanders trequan smith down the field
it'll just make everything else on their
offense uh and their life so much easier
so that was a a good start by drew brees
in that saints offense yesterday kind of
getting off the schneid and getting back
to uh some explosive plays in the past
game
and there's some saltiness to the saints
about the criticism of drew brees alvin
kamara had some comments last week to
reporters and i spoke to camara again
yesterday after the game and and he said
you know we don't care we don't listen
to it drew doesn't keep himself up at
night worried about it he doesn't care
he doesn't listen and
we know that he does because he was
rattling off the stats that people were
pointing out
on you know social media platforms or
wherever yeah a couple of weeks ago they
are paying attention to it and why
shouldn't you anything you can use to
motivate yourself and if sean payton at
some level is using it to needle drew
brees to try to get him to perform
better that's what coaches do and
parcells
was the sean payton mentor of course
sean payton's going to needle guys
that's all parcells ever did yeah so you
use it to get more out of guys and i
think the criticism is one of the
reasons why the saints did what they did
and one of the things kamir told me that
you know they weren't freaked out when
it was 14 nothing because they never got
a chance to get into their offense until
it was 14 nothing and they knew once
they got into their offense once things
settled down they
they'd rack up yards and roll up points
and that's exactly what they did yeah
they did and you know the the other
thing i think that jumps out too and
with sean payton yesterday
stay patient with the run
that's a really good offensive line i do
think the last few weeks he kind of got
away with it just a hair early where you
went man they're gashing them with
camaro and murray like why not just keep
doing that but i also think that kind of
plays into
when brees does
become a little more aggressive throwing
the ball that way and sean payton does
dial up those plays to to back off the
defense just to just a degree
uh that's when you see alvin kamara who
is just phenomenal i mean playing as
good as any running back in football
right now and that's kind of when you
see the offense at its best for the
saints all right first one for me i got
your kryptonite right here award it goes
to the baltimore ravens let me set the
stage for this last year week three they
lost to the chiefs week four they got
upset by the cleveland browns it was the
only
other game that the ravens lost the
entire season
this year week three monday night
football
they lose to the chiefs lamar jackson
calls the chiefs our kryptonite which
was jarring you're conceding the point
forever to the chiefs because superman
never could beat kryptonite and i was
concerned that it was going to take
these ravens a while to reset and reload
and take care of business that's why i
didn't make my best bet
given thirteen and you got lucky you got
lucky by one oh baby covered by one
point but still they covered and i said
if they don't have the setback if they
don't have the letdown if they don't
give in to that defeatist attitude of
you know what we know it's waiting for
us in january it's going to be the
chiefs and we're done
if they don't give in to that they're
going to be fine and they were better
than fine lamar jackson was electric
almost 100 more passing yards he had
that great run where he he celebrated
inside the five and realized there was
still a washington player there and he
got he got chewed out a little bit by
his head coach for doing that but
they
quickly to their credit quickly have
gotten their bearings back and they're
ready to continue to do what they were
doing before they had their encounter
with their kryptonite the chiefs yeah
that's right they got back on track and
you know wasn't always pretty i mean
washington's defense as we saw yesterday
they're they're painting the butt i mean
as we've seen really the whole season so
you're not gonna just steamroll them you
know series after series after series
but i think what you know what we saw to
like to what you're saying yeah was was
was a good sign because it didn't come
easy early on they kind of had a battle
and then okay finally getting in a
rhythm and lamar makes the big play and
you start to go all right well they got
control of this football game certainly
i think that was encouraging no doubt
bounce back win
you know against a team where you knew
they were they knew they were better
than you just didn't want to fall asleep
at the wheel and make it a close game to
where ooh now one play
and we lose or we're in a tight ball
game down the stretch the other thing
too that i think was big is you know
hollywood brown we saw him yesterday a
number of times in the game make some
some field position game changing type
plays that way they really gotta work on
that that to me is like the next area
for the ravens
just in case like you're saying if
kryptonite's in there in january
you can't just say we're gonna run the
ball and smash the chiefs and we think
we're still gonna win that way that's
that's proven that's very dicey that
they're going to have to rely on these
receivers and marquis hollywood brown
and that that group there they're going
to have to start to
really show up consistently in my mind
for them to kind of take that next step
that proverbial next step on the
offensive side of the ball because lack
of wide receiver involvement in the
offense last week for the chiefs is uh
kind of concerning
all right
what else do you got all right let's go
well the uh the same old same old award
the old same old same old award to
russell wilson because it was the same
old russell wilson he was just throwing
bombs all over it doesn't matter if he's
on the east coast the southeast what
you almost got into your old time i know
i did uh movie hey sports did you watch
there russell wilson yesterday the champ
champ he was really good yeah champ
champ what'd you see out there i mean
yeah just russell wilson's unbelievable
he really is and you just sit there
every week and you go i mean can seattle
really go out there and throw bombs
again and just win that way can they do
that again somebody will take away the
bombs right they won't do that it's just
no stopping it right now
he is
freaking unreal deep ball thrower i mean
the ball drops from the clouds and then
metcalf and locket are special and when
you play those two over or you know over
play your hand on those two too much
yes the dave and moores and the olsons
and the fred swains of the world start
to pop up to you seattle this is i'm
this is it seattle this is what they're
going to do all year every game is going
to be a touchdown it doesn't matter
they're going to let russ cook he's
going to throw balls and they're going
to go yep our defense isn't that good
but i bet you we make a play or two
today that gives us one more possession
and that's what they just keep doing you
know the defense yeah they break a lot
but they get a turnover or make a play
every game to kind of give their team
that advantage and
you know i i can't doubt what i'm seeing
there in seattle right now
that game was closer for most of the
contest than
it should have been some were saying
this could be a trap game for the
seattle seahawks the dolphins aren't
horrible they look great last thursday
night against the jaguars they played
the patriots kind of tough they played
the bills a lot closer than they played
the patriots and there was a concern
that there was some danger
for the the seattle seahawks and you
know one of the things
that caused people to call it a trap
game the fact that they had to go from
seattle all the way to miami i mean
you're talking about as far as you could
possibly go and still stay in the united
states other than alaska or hawaii but
dk metcalf told me after the game
they love coming to the east coast and
playing the one o'clock eastern 10 a.m
pacific games they love it they're good
at it and they think that the teams that
they are playing
just kind of
and it's hard to write off how can you
write off the seahawks but right they
they feel like they have an edge against
the seahawks in this setting and they
really don't and i think the seahawks
relish being able to prove over and over
again that they can play these games
where their body tells them it's 10 a.m
but they still go out and play as well
as they do in prime time yeah you know i
mean
whatever
i don't you know the seattle this is
what i like about seattle they're just
edgy that's why like in a year with no
fans or anything like that
one thing i can count on in nfl football
sunday is seattle seahawks are going to
show up and be ready to compete and
throw their body around and be a bunch
of psychos and yeah they'll tell
themselves lies or whatever else you
know but yeah whatever it takes and i'm
sure there is a little bit of that from
the from the home team though i i would
agree with that not that i think it like
really affects the game but i think if i
was a quarterback of another team and
you're playing a west coast team and a
1pm eastern start
you you definitely have that thought
creep in your brain like oh maybe we'll
catch these guys sleeping this week it's
only 10 a.m for them those things do you
know hopefully you don't let down as a
football player because of that but i i
don't i don't doubt that
i'm just saying the seahawks are fueled
they are always and again we we you know
like you said yeah they're always going
to have to lie to yourself you do it
right and you're thinking yeah these
guys think we're going to be easy today
because we think it's 10 a.m
and uh they think they're gonna have an
easy game and and yeah let's just go
kick their butts and remind everyone
that we can play anywhere anytime any
place we're going to compete we're going
to come out we're going to get it done
full stadium
no fans whatever the case may be that's
right and they just keep getting it done
all right from let russ cook to let
dalvin cook i mean it fits him even
better right yes
let's let dalvin cook
vikings changed dramatically
dramatically once dalvin cook started
getting the ball more and doing more
with it i mean one of the reasons you
don't get the ball very much as a
running back is you're not doing much
with it when you have it so you're
punting you have you know it's like the
randy ratio well every time that our
running back runs 25 or more times in a
game we win yeah good luck getting him
to a point where he can run 25 or more
times again that's kind of the battle
you kind of don't get the opportunity to
run the ball 25 times if it's not
working well the last two weeks for the
vikings a game they won over houston a
game they could have and should have won
over tennessee
dalvin cook's got a combined 311 rushing
yards over the last two weeks 22 carries
against the titans 27
against the texans and if the vikings
are going to salvage this season and
make a mad dash
for playoff spot number seven in the nfc
this is what they're going to need
that's the guy i got paid it's it's the
alvin kamara dynamic
you get your running back paid he's no
longer worried about the injury risk
that's on his shoulders it's on your
shoulders and he can go out and he can
play with reckless abandon now he can
still get injured but he's going to go
out and he's going to play hard and
that's what we've seen from dalvin cook
the last two weeks the first two weeks
they just couldn't get anything going
the first two weeks the offense was
abysmal so
if and and this is this is setting the
stage maybe for kirk cousins to start
earning his 33 million a year chris
because they're gonna react to dalvin
cook
playing like he did last year and with
justin jefferson emerging that's right
this vikings offense could be fixed
which makes it easier to play defense
yeah definitely well i mean like you've
said it all along i mean you really have
you've been on this really since last
year but you've been saying it all year
this year i mean yeah the vikings
offense is just if they can't run the
ball we don't know about it but when
they can
we know that they can make plays and it
sets up to one-on-ones downfield and
kirk cousins you know i will say yeah he
made some mistakes early on in the year
but damn
as you know the vikings are horrible at
pass protection so i i would i would say
he's probably getting hit about as many
as as much as any quarterback i've seen
through four weeks but then you know he
has made is even some of the losses some
high level throws where i go damn that's
a good throw i mean he's done a lot of
that uh and especially the last two
weeks where it's really taken off but
you justin jefferson you you said it i
mean he looks like to me like he's a
budding superstar there right now he's
got it all and uh that's kind of
exciting and good good for minnesota and
mike zimmer and especially after last
week i mean what they missed two days of
practice last week you know i mean that
that's got to even be worse for houston
you got a full week minnesota had to sit
at home for two days and they still
you know dominated the football game i
mean houston i think we have a problem
they're in trouble uh they they stink
and they're
um i would like to say once again i was
wrong tony dungy was right i thought
maybe wide receiver by committee could
help in houston no they're better with
deandre hopkins than nobody on the
committee because they can't seem to get
everybody the ball in this wide receiver
by committee
um are you ready for my next one
i am ready
um my monsters of the midway award goes
to the indianapolis colts going into oh
it's not good
bam
showing who the real defense is in town
you know uh i mean
just a phenomenal point
i mean performance by the colts defense
the coast defense i think one of those
units that
not like everybody in the in the
football world fans and everything are
realizing yet how good they are but i
think they're going to start realizing
it now after some of these performances
we're starting to see i mean
this is one of the best defenses in
football if not one the best
they can send just like we've seen some
of these good teams in the super bowl
like the 49ers last year
waves at you up front they have a really
good defensive line they have an awesome
uh linebacker duo and walker and darius
leonard as we know and the secondary
which was a question mark is playing
really good i mean rodney i know he
talked about xavier rhodes last night on
sunday night football and everything
he's right xavier rhodes lost some
weight he's a different guy you know
they got they just they got it going
they really do
and with philip rivers kind of taking
care of the ball and not being stupid
that way
i i'd say watch out for the colts to me
the colts are one of those teams that
are kind of
rallying for you know
upper upper echelon
upper echelon you know uh status
well
you're still not sure i wasn't
i doubled it i didn't sure yes and you
started to enunciate this the the ce on
the end right you were like upper
echelon
um yeah hey look the colts like the
buccaneers like the browns lose week one
what the hell is wrong with them and
they've all won three in a row since
then and uh and the jaguars scoring the
upset of the colts week one they're all
in three since then they're back in the
tank for trevor conversation it's just
it's just unfortunate that it's happened
to the jaguars but that's the thing
every game has a winner and a loser
unless you have a tie all right next one
for me
remodeling
greater than sign rebuilding award goes
to the carolina panthers they're making
the jets look horrible
and and this is a point that we made
last week and it bears repeating as the
panthers beat the cardinals on sunday to
move to two and two it is possible to be
rebuilding
and also competitive
and yeah they're two and oh without
christian mccaffrey in the lineup for
crying out loud and look they didn't
embarrass themselves week one against
the raiders no they didn't embarrass
themselves week two against the
buccaneers and now they've won two in a
row and this is a team
that you just have to watch you just
have to pay attention to teddy
bridgewater a great story
almost as compelling of a story as alex
smith now teddy bridgewater didn't face
a life and death situation like alex
smith did with his severe infection from
his broken leg but teddy bridgewater's
mangled knee that caused players to
become physically ill when it happened
in a walk-through practice yeah on on a
you know a weekday before week one
four years ago
he was done he was never going to be the
same he could not i remember when he
tried to play like a year and a half
after that you could tell that it was
like there was a weight inside that knee
it didn't want to move like now it's
like it never happened the way he moved
with that touchdown run he had yesterday
amazing so it's special it's exciting
and it's an indictment of what's going
on with the jets right now frankly
because you can be rebuilding but still
go out and win football games or not
lose by double digits each and every
week yeah well it it it it definitely is
like it shows or it should show the rest
of the nfl like the rip the band-aid off
effect to rebuild your team it doesn't
have to be that bad to where like oh
we're going to rip the band-aid off and
rebuild and now we're going to be 1-15
that's guaranteed no they did a great
job they said we're going to rip the
band-aid off we're going to start from
scratch we're going to get a lot of
young guys and get some free agents that
are kind of younger too and try to kind
of build a nucleus and go from there i
think first off that was really smart
and the way they orchestrated that in
the off-season and then matt rule and
and company you know that's why the guy
is a damn good coach and why i've been
hearing his name they pick they just
they play complimentary football they
seem to take the right approach to give
themselves the chance to win the game
every week you know yeah they're maybe
not good enough to pull it off but i
think how you started off where they've
been competitive every week even in
those first two losses because they play
complimentary football they understand
what the offense is doing hey offense is
doing this defense we need to play it
this way and uh you said it with teddy
bridgewater some under the radar weapons
there they're kind of a fun team to
watch really and uh good for them
congratulations no doubt about that um
the flip side though what the hell is
wrong with arizona what's wrong well i
mean they they were looking great
through two weeks right now they've lost
a couple of games where if they were
truly a good team they'd be 4-0 right
now these are winnable games these are
breaks before you go back to that meat
grinder of the nfc west well you're you
know we played that clip before of coach
dungy and rodney you know rodney going
like you know cliff kingberry has to
manage the game and run the ball like
that's not gonna happen i don't think i
think like what coach dungey said is
right this is what they are their run
game is only going to be shorter more
short passes an extension right that's
that's really what they want to do
last week kyler murray was too loose
with the football i mean he really he
cost them the game there's there's no
doubt about that with the lions game you
know yesterday
i'm going gonna be it's one of the films
i can't wait to watch because i want to
know what carolina did i know they
contained murray for the most part of
the day again didn't let him scramble
other than one big run kind of later on
in the game when they were way behind
but coverage wise it just seems like
they took away all the easy throws like
all the cliff kingsbury kyler murray oh
you want to play a little soft zone i'm
going to get out of my hand oh there's a
completion for five or six oh here's a
wide receiver screen oh seven or eight
and then they kind of hit you down field
off of that i feel like they never let
the short stuff kind of get going
yesterday and murray and that offense
had a hard time i was more surprised by
the cardinals defense too which i kept
going man i kind of like what i'm seeing
from them and carolina just picked them
apart to your point with teddy
bridgewater i mean i just everything in
carolina has been much better than
expected through four weeks of the nfl
and
you know happy for them no doubt and the
other thing too we're getting to the
point where there's enough film for
teams to see what's happening
offensively and defensively with an
opponent you can game plan more
creatively you can have better insight
and conversely you better be doing the
same thing and you better be self
scouting yourself and making changes to
your tendencies you're going to get
exploited maybe that's some of what's
going on too chris yeah no i i think i
think you're right i think you are right
and uh it shows that they're staying on
top of their tendencies too so i'm i'm i
am i'm excited to kind of see what they
do there and uh
they're building something that's for
sure all right we got one more one more
here i got time for another i mean it's
it's 8 22 a.m eastern time and there's
one specific player in one specific team
that has not been even mentioned don't
give me a hug that's where i want to go
don't give me a heart attack
don't give me a heart attack because
josh allen almost got hurt yesterday
holy cow don't give me heart attack over
don't do that to me don't do that to me
joshua
my boy blew got her i got scared to
death end of the first half he hurts his
non you know his non-throwing shoulder
and you're going oh no i hope he's okay
but i mean buffalo
once again just it's it's all in josh
allen's hands and i just i'm i guess i'm
still an amazement as you could tell
i am but you just see i mean he's just
such a a playmaker that way and they
don't even pretend to be like a balanced
football team anymore they're literally
just like it's a big moment
we're gonna unleash the kraken we're
gonna let allen drop back and we're
hoping we hit stefan diggs 50 yards down
the field but we'll take a 30-yard
completion of that son
i mean he delivers it's just it's truly
amazing what they're doing on the
offensive side of the ball and if he
does get injured and if he can't play oh
they're in trouble barkley they're in
trouble berkeley yeah all due respect
remember there was a time wasn't there a
time where matt barkley was viewed as
like a top prospect do you remember that
oh why did i draft in like the fourth
round i remember i mean he he stayed in
school because everybody was saying he
was going to be the number one pick in
the draft
you know and that's why
you know sometimes we shouldn't let
anchors of sports highlight shows make
draft opinions and evaluations we can
kind of just listen to the people that
know
wait who's that a shot at not you i'm
just other sports highlights announcers
but but but we're going to see him on
sundays
but let me say it this year since
college football is back in every game
you see we're going to see that guy on
sundays next year well not unless he's
visiting your house you're not going to
see him on sundays next year because
most of these guys are not going to be
playing on sundays next year just the
very select few
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports